Language is beautiful.
I think it's the most beautiful of human creations.
I think it's the loveliest thing that our brains have invented.
It entertains, it educates, it enlightens,
but what I like the most about language
is that it empowers.
I want to leave you with this.
This is a photograph of my collaborators,
my earliest collaborators
when I started working on language
and autism and various other things.
The girl's name is Pavna,
and that's her mother, Kalpana.
And Pavna's an entrepreneur,
but her story is much more remarkable than mine,
because Pavna is about 23.
She has quadriplegic cerebral palsy,
so ever since she was born,
she could neither move nor talk.
And everything that she's accomplished so far,
finishing school, going to college,
starting a company,
collaborating with me to develop Avaz,
all of these things she's done
with nothing more than moving her eyes.
Daniel Webster said this:
He said, "If all of my possessions were taken
from me with one exception,
I would choose to keep the power of communication,
for with it, I would regain all the rest."
And that's why, of all of these incredible applications of FreeSpeech,
the one that's closest to my heart
still remains the ability for this
to empower children with disabilities
to be able to communicate,
the power of communication,
to get back all the rest.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Thank you. (Applause)
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. (Applause)